Welcome back.
We're on problem number 12.
If k is a positive integer, what
is the least value of k
for which the square root
of 5k/3 is an integer?
So this whole thing has
to be an integer.
If the whole thing is going to
be an integer, the thing
inside of the square root has
to be an integer as well.
The square root of a
fraction is never
going to be an integer.
So 5k/3 is going to
be an integer.
And we could also immediately
say that k has to be a
multiple of 3.
That's the only way this is
going to be an integer.
But let's think about what
type of a perfect
square this has to be.
This perfect square, it has
to be divisible by 5.
How do I know that?
Well, let's just rewrite
it as 5 times k/3.
It has to be a multiple of 5,
and this has to be an integer,
which we just said. k has
to be divisible by 3.
The only way that this whole
thing is going to be an
integer is if k/3
is an integer.
So what is the smallest
perfect square that is
divisible by 5?
Because we want k to be the
smallest possible number.
The smallest possible integer.
So the smallest perfect square
that is a multiple of 5 is, of
course, 5 squared,
which is 25.
So let's set this equal to 25.
So 5k/3 is going to
be equal to 25.
Let's see, we can multiply
both sides by 3.
You get 5k is equal to 75.
Divide both sides by 5.
You get k is equal to 15.
And you can try it out.
Put 15 in here, this whole
thing becomes 25.
And then the square
root becomes 5.
And they're all integers.
Next problem.
OK, they drew some boxes
or some shapes.
This one's 1.
And this one looks something
like this.
That's 1, 1.
And then this one looks
something like this.
This is 2, 1.
The figures above represent
three pieces of cardboard.
All angles of the cardboard
pieces are right angles.
Fair enough.
All short sides have length
1, and all long
sides have length 2.
Which of the following figures
could have been made from only
the three pieces of cardboard
without overlapping them.
So let's draw these choices.
So choice one looks like this.
It comes down like this.
This is 2.
This comes down like this.
This goes like this.
And this length is 3.
So maybe I'll try to fit the
biggest piece in and see what
I have left over.
So the only place where
that big piece can
fit in is right here.
That's the only place the
big piece can fit in.
And then I could fit
in the small piece.
I could put it here.
But then have no space.
That or that is not enough
space for this piece.
So one does not work.
Choice two.
So it has length 4 and it
goes 2, 1, like that.
And then it goes 2, then
it comes back.
So this is 2, 2, this is 1.
So where can I fit
the big piece?
Let's try that first. Well, the
really only place where it
will fit, because it's 3
wide, is right here.
This is the only place where
the big piece will fit.
And then where can I fit
the small piece?
Well, this looks like a pretty
obvious place for the small
piece, because, obviously, the
medium piece isn't going to be
fit right there.
And can I fit the
medium piece?
Can this piece fit here?
Well, sure, I just have
to rotate it.
And how do I know that?
Well, let me show, if
I can visualize it.
If I rotate it so that this side
becomes this side, and
that this side, right here,
becomes this side.
And then I could keep going.
I could say this side
is this side.
This is actually
strangely fun.
This side is this side.
And I think you get
the picture.
This side is this side.
So I think you get the idea.
I just rotated it.
So this one works.
Choice two works.
Let's look at choice three.
Choice three looks like this.
It's also 4 high, go out 1, down
step-- this looks like a
step-- goes down 2.
Then it comes out like that.
It comes like that.
And this is 4, 1, 1, 2, 1.
So where can we fit
the big piece?
The big piece is 3 wide.
So this is the only part that's
3 wide, but there's no
place to stick the bottom
part of the big piece.
The big piece could fit like
this, but there's no place to
put this part.
So the big piece, I can't figure
out a way to make the
big piece fit.
And I don't think it can,
because this is the only part
that's 3 wide, because
it has to be 3 wide.
So choice three is also
not the answer.
So the answer is two only,
and that's choice C.
Next problem.
Problem 14.
How many integers greater than
20 and less than 30 are each
the product of exactly two
different numbers, both of
which are prime?
Exactly two different numbers,
both of which are-- so let's
just list out all the numbers.
Between 20 and 30, not including
those two, because
greater than 20, less than 30.
So 21, 22, 23, 24, 25,
26, 27, 28, 29.
So should we count 1 and
the number as factors?
Well, no, because 1 is
not a prime number.
Prime numbers are all the
numbers greater than or equal
to 2 that have 1 and itself
as the only factors.
So let's see how many factors
other than 1 and itself are
both different and both prime.
So this has 3 and 7,
and that's all I
can get out of it.
And these are both prime,
so this works.
This has 2 times 11.
These are both prime.
I can't think of any other two
numbers that divide into 22.
So that one works.
23 only has 1 times 23.
1 isn't prime.
I mean, all of these also have
the kind of identity factors,
so it's not 23.
24 has 2 times 12, and
6 times 4, and none
of those are prime.
So 24 doesn't work.
25 has 5 times 5.
Both are prime, but they're not
different numbers, so that
doesn't work.
2 times 13 goes to 26 and that's
the only factor, so
that works.
27 has 3 times 9, but 9 isn't
prime, it's a composite
number, divisible by 3,
so that doesn't work.
28 has 2 times 14, and 7 times
2 and-- so it has multiple
factors and 14 isn't prime,
so it doesn't work.
29 is prime, so it doesn't
have any other different
numbers, two different
numbers that divide
into it that are prime.
It only has 1 times 29.
It doesn't have anything else,
and 1 isn't prime.
So there's 1, 2, 3 choices.
So that's D.
I actually think this was a
little badly worded because, I
don't know, you could argue that
the number itself is a
factor-- or I guess the product
of exactly two numbers
and 1 can't count.
It has to be the product of two
numbers, and so you can't
count 1 and itself because
1 is not a prime number.
Both of the numbers
that make up the
product have to be prime.
Problem number 15.
So they drew this triangle.
They tell us that this
is 7 minus x.
This is 7 plus x.
This is 10.
This is 90 degrees.
And they say, in the figure
above is a right triangle.
What is the value of
49 plus x squared?
So let's do the Pythagorean
theoreum.
This squared plus this squared
has to equal that squared.
So 7 minus x, squared plus
7 plus x, squared is
going to equal 100.
This equals 49 minus
2x, plus x squared.
This is equal to plus 49 plus
2x, plus x squared, and that
equals 100.
This minus 2x and this plus 2x
are going to cancel out.
And now this is what?
49 plus 49, that's the same
thing as 2 times 49.
And then you have
x squared plus x
squared, plus 2x squared.
I could have multiplied this
out, but you'll see why I
didn't, because I want to
preserve that 49 in there.
And that equals, so this is
100, this equals 100.
Factor out the 2.
You get 2 times 49, plus x
squared is equal to 100.
Preserve the 49.
And then divide both
sides by 2.
You get 49 plus x squared
is equal to 50.
And we are done.
That's the answer.
That's choice A.
See you in the next video.